هنا في منطقه ارض اللواء في محافظه الجيزه
تعيش الالاف من الاسر اليمنيه هذا الشارع
فيه العديد من المحال والمطاعم والمقاهي
التي تحمل اسماء يمنيه اغلب من يعملون من
اليمنيين الذين اضطرتهم ظروف الحرب للجوء
الى مصر هربا من ميليشيات الحوثي محمد ترك
صنعاء منذ شهور قليله ليعمل كبائع للاسماك
بسبب الكهرباء ما فيش ما ما فيش كهرباء
ما فيش بترول كل شيء يعني متداول كل شيء
تدور ودور وفي احد هذه العقارات تعيش
السيده ايناس خام التي هربت هي واولادها
بعد اغتيال زوجها السيده ايناس تعيش
منتقله من بيت الى بيت وتطهر وجبات
اليمنيه لبيعها
اولادنا بالتعليم
وبدون اقامات نتيجه الظرف المادي واحد
يشتغل في مطعم يا مطعم الواحه يعني الكبير
والثاني يعني الان
في ثانويه يعني اخر سنه المشهد السياسي
واليمني يفرض نفسه على جميع اليمنيين
المقيمين في مصر النسب المبدئيه تشير الى
وجود ما بين 700 الف ومليون يمنيين في مصر
منذ انطلاق الثوره اليمنيه النسبه الاكبر
تركت اليمن بعد سيطره الميليشيات الحوثيه
على السلطه عام 2014
اغلب من التقيناهم ياملون بانتهاء الحرب
ليتمكنوا من العوده لبلادهم في الحياه
التي وضع اليمني
الحرب في كل مكان واسال الله صالح
الذي يعمل كثار عقارات يؤكد حرصه على
توفير اكبر قدر ممكن من المساعده اليمنيين
اللاجئين في مصر
اللي عاوز حاجه مننا بنجيبها له على
الاجمل يعني لو بخمسه ممكن ثلاثه ثلاثه
ونص وتبقى ايناس في متابعه مستمره لاخبار
اليمن اخبار تركز على عمليات القتل
والسلبي والاختطاف التي تقوم بها مليشيات
الحوثي واقصر ما يصير غضبها هي وغيرها من
اليمنيين هي اخباره رفض هذه الميليشيات
لجميع مبادرات السلام وجهود التسويه التي
تبقيها هي وغيرها بعيدا عن بلدهم الحبيب
احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره